the gyro can experience that so what
we're talking about was the difference
between the way the media depicts it and
the way it is
is there anybody that's got it right is
there any movie that you watch you go
that's pretty goddamn close I don't know
they're all they're all close ish you
know but a lot of them are very
Hollywood IIST mmm they have to be maybe
I get it
right you know I understand they're
telling a story right you know unless
they're doing a documentary it's just a
story but I kind I can say that Saving
Private Ryan was super close mm-hmm not
obviously it wasn't for that but my
dad's dad said he had to step out of the
theater when he went to go see that oh
because he could smell diesel he
remembered it it was that strong of a
memory for him yeah Sark was he at
Normandy no he he did comment landings
in the South Pacific with the Marine
Corps that [ __ ] opening scene when
they get on the beach it's it's it's
tough [ __ ] nuts man the idea that
that was the only way that they could
handle that situation that they had to
do it that way can't imagine being one
of those guys that has to get off those
boats that was there that was there good
better best scenario yeah yeah this is
this is House has to happen how many
people died on day thousands I'm not
positive on that but it was thousands of
people perished that day there was
something that someone did to
commemorate the anniversary of the event
and they did something that represented
every body of everyone who died did it
like on the beach like with a number of
hair goes 425,000 allied and German
troops were killed wounded or went
missing during the Battle of Normandy
209 allied casualties Jesus Christ it's
[ __ ] insane that's [ __ ] insane I
mean I remember my granddad has and I
knew he told me these things before I
joined about storming a beach in
Pacific and everybody left right front
and back at him dying going up the sand
you know so but that those are the kinds
of things that it's tough to yeah that's
[ __ ] insane that's the thing it's a
thing all over the sand and it
represents all the different people that
died and it's just everywhere everywhere
you look so that if you were a person
who really had this abstract idea that
this war went down there that gives you
a visual representation of what it must
have looked like yeah you can kind of
almost get it in your head like it makes
it more visceral yeah just look and see
got many [ __ ] bodies and that was the
best-case scenario for these guys yeah
that's the best-case scenario that's why
they did it that way y'all right it's
terrifying
god damn you know and it's it's stuff
like that or like a month before I went
to Afghanistan it's about a month is
when extortion 17 happen I'm like [ __ ]
I'm going there to replace those guys it
makes it really really like some some
things sound home really well and some
things don't
and for me that did
[Applause]